ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi
domenica quindi siamo su e book ragazzi
nell'ultimo mese i server di è più visto
sono non so se le hanno buttato una
bomba nucleare ma non bank azzo quindi
non lo so non vi assicuro nulla spero
funzioni
andiamo col primo slim world guardo alla
ragazza devo riuscire a capire come
cazzo allora femminismo sono
emozionatissimo perché era da un secolo
che non mi partiva è primis è fantastico
se passava un altro po che non giocava
rete mi ricordavo manco più i nomi dei
personaggi lega va beh non importa mi
sono incastrati
e che cazzo ragazzi ma chi cazzo ma io
non ho parole per il secondo me hanno
hanno chiuso i server di itunes per
rincoglionire maggiormente i personaggi
ciò questa teoria andiamo con è di chi
se ne frega zen ger 2 giorno no no kids
puzzoni piedi lo sa i ragazzi devo
ricordarmi come caso si gioca perché da
un prezzo non è che cosa ci abbiate
pazienza perché c'è un altro abbia
attaccato al culo maledizione opposto
quello che andava tolto ne vuoi un po ok
mi sa di no perché mi sparano addosso
cosa hai fatto è vi è rapinato una banca
fammi capire ragazzi per ok
brown o uno sguardo è da secoli che non
facciano ragazzino mi ricordo neanche
più come si gioca se ne posto si trova
una tale ragazzi preparati i camini
perché li porto io i regali o creduloni
consci dei ragazzi mi manca mi mancavano
sti livelli ed casa spa ed era un
cartone che guardavo sempre più da
piccolo che cazzo ci fa qui aspettiamo
anche il cazzo ragazzi ma sta cosa
oscena
non ho mai visto una cosa del genere e
carnola meglio io io non ho parole
prima vista chi ha fatto tutto livello
ma è un genio e cielo fra red christmas
world cloro che culo a sturla ho trovato
lo smog trolley natale cioè po meglio di
così non poteva andare a perché c'è quel
folletto ammesso tipo a 90 gradi come se
lo volesse prendere nei cup ranzi
ma allora sei bastardo me fa rilanciarmi
le spade e un uomo incredibile suo club
la mia vendetta è stata atroce ragazzi
devo beccare babbo natale ma non ho più
le squadre disponibili quindi userò
questo pezzo di folletto
siamo a beccare babbo natale per vincere
c'è ma allora aspettare un attimo se io
vinco sto fuori trovi nessun bambino
avrà regalo sto natale non prendetevela
con me ragazzi ce la devo fare non è
così impossibile maledizione sicilia ma
poi il your bones finalmente ragazzi ci
avevo nostalgia list i livelli devi
darmi in aumento devi darmi un [ __ ]
aumento è capito o non sono stato chiaro
potere gorgonzola e cazzo fa ragazzi e
un 69 al contrario ragazzi come cazzo
fai
no no no no no no no vieni giochi e
salvato sul presente ma tornerò tornerò
a riprendermi il mio lavoro ragazzi sta
diventando air assassini modo collo
bella non ho capito il sé ma perché mi
sono infilato una spada nel culo no no
no no ma basta niente è una mossa di
pokémon credo ragazzi sechi amico per la
pelle e ciechi amico per il culo e
sembra che non c'è più stia godendo 99
91 per cento impossible era un secco che
non lo faccio così blair estivi lo posso
capire che da un bel pezzo che non ti
tengo in allenamento ma non sei scusato
devi vincere subito non riuscire a
vincere allora ragazzi non è così
difficile a particolar che one da solo
tratto quindi non è una cazzata vincere
steve era cazzata no no no no molto
marcato
ammettilo sì perché lo stai facendo per
farmi incazzare film e lo firmerò
sì credo che è andata di culo e va bene
così ap disfarci cos'è sta roba
il nome ok spiegatemi perché una donna
sta ingrossando un uomo ragazzi ok il
solo aveva pure l'urlo ragazzi sa cosa
non la sto capendo abbiate pazienza
dove devo andare stai ferma donna
mollami ho preso il tuo culo
ho preso il tuo maledettissimo culo.ora
mollami il ventre molle
ragazzi questo è kamasutra puro su una
moto
allora io devo riuscire a trascinarmi
trascinati cazzo hanno perso una gatta
allora devi o il tuo culo si saldano
perché ragazzi perché devo uccidere
babbo natale parla stronzo dove babbo
dove babbo di melo subito in tre secondi
12 affanculo non ha parlato ragazzi io
io non ho pietà non ho nessuna pietà
doveva portare qualcuno così come anche
il tempo di rispondere ragazzi a lui me
lo sta indicando e di là perfetto grazie
mille devo andare
hai mentito non di jump contest cos'è
sta roba
devo saltare avanti il po di potenza
tipo adesso vai così mollami donna molla
mibac e cazzo
le donne quanto sono appiccicose
maledizione rivi mollarmi o ti lascio io
brava così grandissima spinta che ci vai
a prepararmi ho seguito le ho letto
debito agli arti donna più staccati
malizia ma porca [ __ ]
[Musica]
io ragazzi più più gioco e meno trovo
senso ha detto ultimamente sta andando
fuori di testa
vai con lo speed ball al primo tentativo
non sono molto come un deficiente tipo
adesso ma io non ci posso veramente
credere per un cazzo di m presumo io
debba continuare così per un bel pezzo
vero
posso crederci che sono effettivamente
fatto a quattro zampe
mr jump devo sapere le frecce di poco
luca sul campo il mio bene avevo detto
accoglie ogni distanza si sono ancora
sono ancora vivo ciò semplicemente una
freccia di 4 metri nel pene ma e sono
dettagli vai tu che sei un uomo cazzo
eri un uomo perché adesso mi sa un po
meno abbia ma non importa mai così tante
epic boys chiusa ams vai così allora
vado col padre di look
credo che debba perfetto look e mezzo
andato sì ok ho fatto una cosa epica ho
fatto un'altra cosa epica sto
continuando a fare cosepi che con la bce
vede un bel pezzo che non andavo così in
una maniera tanto pro madonna anche
davanti anche la marchi che ormai siamo
professionisti della madonna ma ragazzi
direi di provare un po di via livelli
che veramente un secolo che non li
faccio raga scusatemi 99 per cento il
prossimo per farvi j
era un casino fa vj attento alla minima
maione milan è pronto a testarle così
non sono morto a casa il successo ci
devo provare a vincere se riesco tipo
così per nel culo no hekuran ole ole ole
ole cazzo ok perfetto tanto di testa
dura l'abbiamo capito noi riuscire è
comunque noi infatti mi è cresciuto un
pene maledizione non ce l'avevo primo ok
mi si è staccato perfetto era era
sostituibile ma ragazzi non è cosa
fattibile sta roba come faccio io volevo
tipo schivare così ho letto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
direi di fare l'ultimo ragazzi la sfida
di fa vj non ho idea di che cosa sia ma
ci prova facciamo col padre di york la
sfida la sfida di fa vj perfetto già il
titolo mi min ispira un casino ma il
livello un po meno pajhwok
puoi vincere l'ho solo ok come non detto
che i ragazzi è più difficile è prevista
devo tipo schivare il primo surplus ma
ok perfetto ma che cazzo è troppi ora
devo prima inchiodare tipo così ok
perfetto e già mi sono salvato mi sono
salvato bartolini sul cast un casco
perfetto come non detto sono ancora vivo
nonostante uno pesa di 300 kg mi sia
piombata addosso
sono ancora vivo e continua ad essere
vivo e continua come va ma è immortale
sto tizio ai ragazzi vai così ci posso
credere ghazi sto scrivendo tutto
[Musica]
ma è stata la cosa incredibile ma questa
faccia mi sembra quella di uno che
scherza direi che però ci possiamo
concludere qui ragazzi siccome lo
speciale uscirà mercoledì mi prendere un
pochettino per registrarlo quindi
ragazzi fino allo speciale non usciranno
video perché ci mettono parecchio ad
evitarlo a farlo a spero comunque che vi
piaccia lo vedrete il 27 e quindi
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto come al solito servito mi è
piaciuta lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come ogni
video trovate nella descrizione essere
per i siti scrivete quindi ci rivediamo
nel prossimo video da ragazzi